[Music]
one of the things we consistently talk
about here at the Rubin report is why
it's important to judge people as
individuals and not as a collective you
as an individual are much more than your
immutable characteristics be it your
skin color your religion or your
sexuality to judge you on those
characteristics is actually what the
essence of prejudice really is prejudice
of course means to prejudge so if you
look at a black person or a Muslim
person or a gay person and think that
you know what they think or more
importantly how they should think based
on those characteristics then you are
actually the one who's being prejudiced
sadly many of the people who accuse
others of bigotry and racism these days
are often the people who practice this
brand of prejudice the most without even
realizing that they're doing so just
look at some of the things that my
friends larry elder Maajid Nawaz and
ayaan Hirsi Ali are called
by the so called tolerance side when you
look at a group of people and you think
you know what they should think or
what's best for them based on those
outward characteristics and not what's
going on in their own minds you not only
lock people into your preconceived
notions of what they are but stifle the
voices of the minorities within these
minorities this is why the voices of
black conservatives and gay Muslims for
example are so relevant and interesting
today if you really listen to these
minorities within the minorities you
will judge these people on their
thoughts their logic and their reason
instead of simply how they look or who
they love in a way the very existence of
these free thinkers within these
minority communities flips identity
politics on its head showing the flaws
of this postmodern intersectional way of
thinking just see how quickly those who
preach identity politics turn on black
or Latino people who have conservative
political beliefs or how easily they
dismiss gays or women who dare talk
about how poorly they're treated in
Islamic societies identity politics only
works if you believe that the most
important quality about each of us are
the attributes which we are born with
thus cannot change rather than the ideas
which we come to learn I view this
twisted ideology as a true
essential danger for the tolerant and
liberal albeit flawed country that
America is Martin Luther King Junior's
desire for his children to be judged by
the content of their character and not
the color of their skin is being
undermined by the very people who
purport to be the tolerant ones
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is
the CEO of the Thurgood Marshall College
Fund Johnny C Taylor the organization
represents nearly three hundred thousand
students who attend the 47 historical
black colleges in America today
I heard Johnny speak at an event in
Dallas a couple months ago and was blown
away by his passion his commitment to
educating young people and his desire to
move past identity politics we're going
to talk about politics race and much
more has the role of the black college
changed as we've become a more fair and
just society that's just one of the many
questions I'll ask Johnny and I'll only
judge him by the content of his answers
not the color of his skin
[Music]
we're continuing our partnership with
learn liberty today and joining me is
the president and CEO of the Thurgood
Marshall scholarship fund the only
national organization representing the
nearly three hundred thousand students
attending America's 47 historically
black colleges Johnny C Taylor welcome
to the Reuben report so glad to be here
I got to tell you man I and I just did
tell you but now I'll repeat it since
the cameras are on you we've been doing
this thing with learn Liberty for a
little over a year so and they've sent
us some great authors and professors and
thinkers I've never requested any one
you sir
are the first person I requested because
I saw you speak a couple months back at
a conference for academics had to do a
lot about free speech and liberty and
all sorts of things and you gave the
keynote address on the final night and I
thought this guy is possibly the most
passionate speaker I've ever seen in my
life thank you
where does that passion come from well
let's start there before we even talk
about what you do just the passion that
you had I was just like that I gotta get
that guy on the show so yours
interesting I spent my career in the
entertainment space the media space
Paramount Pictures Spelling
entertainment blockbuster entertainment
so all of
life was doing that kind of stuff making
money that's right but I always had this
yearning for the community and and how
higher education could play into in you
know sort of fixing what was going on in
my community and I say the community I
mean all of Americans but particularly
african-americans and there were so many
conversations that didn't occur weren't
allowed to occur and so I took this new
role at the Thurgood Marshall College
Fund representing black colleges I
didn't attend a black college I often
say I'm a beneficiary of it because so
many of my teachers and doctors and
lawyers did but I didn't my parents
didn't attend a black college but I
thought this was such an opportunity to
come in and really begin to influence
how young people you know our future
leaders how they think about the world
and then to challenge them my legal
education by definition sort of taught
me to challenge the status quo to be
able to argue both sides or in some
instances three sides of any argument
and so that's what came from I really I
don't sleep at night sometimes thinking
about where America is headed and that's
where the passion comes from I'm
genuinely concerned about where we're
going yeah I feel that too and we kind
of hit that a little bit before now we
got to do it all over right now tell me
a little bit more about your resume
before we get to what you've been doing
these last couple years because yeah you
just mentioned some of us up I mean
you've got a pretty prime your Lincoln's
got to be pretty fast in the last
somewhat like eight pages that's right
god is good but tell me a little bit
about that because I think it does form
sort of you know how you end up sitting
across from me here yes so I began my
career well let me back up I did the
undergraduate work in the University of
Miami I'm a born and raised in Florida
so I'm for you I gotta give my shout out
to my school and even I finished school
went to law school in Iowa Drake
University and I came back to South
Florida to practice at a big law firm
Janet Reno was one of my was the first
female partner so I'm hating myself it
takes your way back yeah and then began
my practice sat on a plane one day now
met a I did not know at the time a
billionaire wayne Huizenga who had this
small little business called blockbuster
that he was building I went in as the
third lawyer on staff and
we went through this huge acquisition
spree and you know you remember
blockbuster was on every corner yeah so
did that Vikon bought us so I've spent
my time as a lawyer as an HR executive
and then ultimately once Vikon bought us
and worked for Sumner at Viacom Sumner
Redstone and then my last corporate gig
was running a business a subsidiary for
Barry Diller in New York so I literally
have had all the back office functions
and then ran front line operator running
a business for Barry yeah came to TMC up
in 2010 as the CEO so you've been doing
this for now about seven years and
you're actually about to shift onto
something else which will which we'll
get to a little later yes but tell me a
little bit about what the scholarship
fund actually does what is the purpose
because I know a certain amount of
people because I know a lot of your
thoughts on on the diversity memo and
all that stuff it almost sounds counter
to what the Thurgood Marshall
scholarship fund might do right so the
college fund was actually created by the
way we were created as the scholarship
fund Thurgood Marshall scholarship fund
about a decade ago we changed the name
to broaden the remit to the College Fund
so they're good Marshall college fund
and we really only do four things
scholarships we provide scholarships for
the absolutely most talented students so
this is not sort of a social services
feel-good for kids who didn't get a shot
K through 12 these are the brightest
kids who frankly just have money not
what they need so scholarships that are
needed and sort of need and merit-based
then capacity building we've talked with
our schools a lot about there was a time
when HBCUs captive market if you were
black anyone to go to college you
attended a black college well everything
changed be careful what you pray for we
asked for diversity we got it we asked
for integration we got it and so now
black students have options and so black
colleges the historically black colleges
have got to step up so the second thing
is to build their capacity to be
attracted the third thing that we do is
government affairs I mean a lot of
advocacy and policy work to make sure
that we're not making emotional
decisions we want to do what is good for
our communities and what's good for this
country those are really the three
things that we focus on as as a fund and
that's
work that we do and the thing that that
most of the folks frankly don't realize
is historically black colleges are not
EBC use they're not exclusively black
colleges in fact or currently four of
our member schools aren't majority white
really majority white so they are still
historically black colleges because the
H is historically black no necessarily
currently black yeah so West Virginia
State in Bluefield State College both in
West Virginia Lincoln University in
Missouri Kentucky State these are
schools that while technically are not
technically are actually HBCUs are have
more white students than black students
and those are some of the things that
people don't understand this is not
about race per se yeah
how much battling is there over what it
means to be historically black versus
currently diverse because I would
imagine you've got you know ideas and
and academics and administrators who are
probably pretty entrenched in keeping
things just looking at it by numbers not
necessarily diversity of thought that's
and all that so you must be dealing with
that constant oh you have no idea ugly
and it's interesting because I'm
surprised and I know we'll talk about
some of this but I'm surprised at the
number you'd like to think millenials
you know we think Millennials and we
group the men in their open and they're
diverse in their well I was surprised
we've had some students really not
faculty not alumni but students 18 your
19 year olds take great issue with the
fact that the institutions are more
diverse than they were they wanted to
come to an all-black institution anyway
get there and realize that we have
international students and white
students and Hispanic students they
really push back so that's been a real
surprise to me yeah how do you break
through that well you you continue first
of all you explain to them that HBCU is
not EB C you then you start with it and
then you also then explain I find myself
to often times when I'm talking to them
saying let me just put yourself in this
situation so just recently one of our
campuses really what does a group of
students were really upset because in
fact it was all of the national news
well students came on the campus of
Howard University wearing the make
America great again oh yeah that's right
and I said I just wanted the student
leaders that pull to the status I don't
want you just for a second to ask me how
you think this would play out group of
black students right after Obama
selected go visit Liberty University's
campus they have on the wonderful Obama
t-shirts where they're proud of this new
president and they were literally run
off of campus they were threatened they
were harassed how do you think that will
go over and so what I find myself doing
is just literally put yourself in that
situation and tell me why this is that
different and then you get that pause
that moment by the way that's what
motivates me to do my work because
that's the way you influence the sort of
the narrative yeah and how these young
people think you have to just stop and
say I get how you feel right now
emotionally about this but for just a
second let's flip the script and tell me
how this works and you're smart you're
bright yeah tell me how this works out
that's that's really part of what
motivates me to do the work yeah and
that's what we need more right I mean
because everybody seems hysterics
hysterical over over emotionals that's
like it's see like I can understand that
if I if I was black and I wanted to go
to a historically black college and I
got there and I thought it was gonna be
80% black and I got there and I was like
wait a minute I'm actually still a
minority here the the emotional part I
can understand it being like this
doesn't feel right to me but then when
you hear that and you go what things
actually are changing integration is
really this is this is all good this is
this is the purpose right I'm free to
pray for right you know I often say be
careful what you pray for this is
exactly what we said we wanted is the
opportunity to choose kind of that's
what I can tell you that's what my
great-grandparents yeah that's what my
got in fact Thurgood Marshall himself
well folks don't realize this Thurgood
Marshall didn't choose to go to Howard
University Law School Thurgood Marshall
fact of the matter is applied to the
University of Maryland was denied
admission to that law school well I went
to Howard because it was the college for
black students law students for black
students and so you just have to think
about it he then subsequently brought
lawsuits to actually stop that very
thing again this was an anti HBCU the
message was I want to be able to choose
irrespective of my skin color where I go
to school so all of us should have
predicted that we would be right where
we are today yeah what I find is
young folks just don't understand the
history and then the older people
refused to tell the animist so what's
going on there because I don't play
there is so much nonsense the media is
so complicit in this yes I I don't you
know and identity Pollock says has
become so rooted in everything that I
don't blame the young people who are
misguided yeah I want to get through to
them and and all that it's the other
people that are talking with the older
people and the academics that are afraid
to speak what happened there did you see
it change i I did I saw it you know and
and where when I was in school you're
encouraged to be a little bit of a
provocateur always respectfully you
never there was no no one wanted you to
go out and hurt someone's feelings but
we were encouraged in law school for
example to look at things from all
different sorts of perspectives I was
given a case once where you'd have to
represent the plaintiff and then turn
around and go against that winner
you know defend them so we've just lost
that in education now and I gotta tell
you more and more I'm talking to
students who say you know I feel a
certain way but I know that if I either
utter those my thoughts even in a
question format in the classroom I'd be
attacked by from my professor it would
impact my participation in class Green
that that portion of my grade also and
more importantly what do you say to kids
I say when they say that perhaps you're
at the wrong school I said you got a
vote with your feet College is not about
it's supposed to be a time to explore
and to grow if you already knew what you
needed to know to sort of live in life
and be successful then you don't need to
spend five or six years and hundreds of
thousands of dollars if you aren't the
same person that you walked in the door
at the end of your freshman year then
you were cheated yeah and I tell them
you should challenge the institution and
give you a better education and
sometimes that the way you get better is
to have to confront ideas that you don't
necessarily embrace you don't understand
them one situation that that sort of
comes up and I think it helps my
students a lot understand where I come
from I said you know listen I was an
employment lawyer early in my career and
at that time there was a big question
for example around whether or not gay
lesbian sexual orientation was covered
under title seven okay big question
gender and sex was clear if
you were being discriminated against on
the basis of something else than sort of
sexual orientation that wasn't covered I
actually brought those cases and made
those arguments I defended them that was
not the intent of the Congress and this
was ridiculous
etc even that gender is something that's
innate you're born that way and well gay
and lesbian maybe not so much
fast forward yeah we're here early
that's 1992 ok I think it's important
that's right to context that's right put
it in context now fast forward you began
to evolve and grow you start sitting
down and getting to know people who are
different than you are or that your
family is or that you you just you began
to evolve and it challenges your own
notions of what is right and what is
wrong and maybe you conclude there is no
right or wrong here this is just life
that we're evolving as a human species
kind of even I've had to do that and
there's so many instances of that in my
own life and so when you begin to have
conversations in the context of the
classroom with students you see the
growth that's the beauty that should be
the beauty of it instead what I'm seeing
more and more davidís they're actually
retarding the grad students you're not
encouraged to think you come in thinking
a certain way your professors want you
to think a certain way your institution
wants you to think a certain way but
here's the problem the real problem is
then you go to work and you have to
confront the reality of you know you're
not protected in this bubble you've got
to live and work next to people who
don't look like you and frankly that's a
chalice is something that people talk
about a lot when they talk about black
colleges the only I don't question the
relevancy of HBCUs I think that's a dumb
argument it's a dumb question there is a
fair question
that is posed if you have gone to a
black elementary school middle school
grew up in a black community and then
you went to a black college the first
meaningful interaction that you can add
with people who are not black is in the
workplace you're gonna be at a
disadvantage
yeah just practically speaking and so
you it has some downside tons of upside
by the way being a majority and minority
community black colleges give you a very
special and nurturing environment to
grow in
but there's a cost to that yeah is that
just the natural evolution of the way
humans are that if you have a legit
grievance you may need a different place
or for Thurgood Marshall who did not get
accepted to the Maryland law school so
he needed a place to go to completely
legit in that time in place but that
eventually we if a quality works because
the arc does bend towards justice that
eventually you slowly need these things
less it doesn't mean that there's no use
for them but you but a lot of people are
sort of addicted to that original pain
or instance or whatever you want to call
it but you nailed it I mean that none of
us it's it's it's addictive I mean
that's a problem in weaning yourself off
of that is difficult and that's not
limited to black people or any group of
people it's just that you get used to it
yeah and this notion that we were to
create remember even the concept of
affirmative action was supposed to be
remedial mm-hmm it was not supposed to
go on forever right but what happens is
if you get used to it and it's a benefit
that a Newars to you and people who look
like you it's really tough to one day
say okay that's done I have a
seven-year-old daughter and I you know
there's a point at which she's gonna
come off of Daddy's credit card he's
gonna fight me yeah if it's a teen if
it's twenty eight if it's thirty eight
the day that I decide you now have to
leave the nest and figure this out
yourself if it's thirty eight K I move
in with you we're done right but you're
right your lunch is something that
that's um it's even think about just in
real life that's the thing that I'm
intrigued by is I could not wait until I
turned 18 so that I could leave my nest
my momma and my daddy's house and go and
start creating my own and I'm seeing
some of them for economic reasons but
just everyone sort of staying at home
and they want it's a very different
world that we live in right now and I'm
intrigued by it yeah how much of this
also is about the family in general
that's one of the things when I've had a
couple particularly in this case when
I've had black conservatives on you know
like larry elder talking about the black
family you just mentioned your mom and
your dad so i I suspect they're still
married no they're not now okay so that
that's interesting but they were for
obviously most of you
childhood how much of that structure is
related to all of this why then you
can't necessarily deal with outside
influences or any of that stuff so I
struggle with that I struggle with that
because because of the realities of
slavery the black community was always
largely maternally run mm-hmm dad and
mom were separated family the family
unit in the traditional sense didn't
exist so and we were successful in spite
of that yeah so I I'm not so sure that I
fit now would I
all day I think the value of having mom
and dad in the home and frankly at some
point grandparents and home to build
that in that I think it's incredibly
important but I'm not prepared to say
that's why everything is wrong as I
pointed out my parents ultimately got
we're divorced and all to have two
sisters we both went to college all
three of us rather we're successful have
great lives nobody's been to jail no one
has eight kids that you know so I don't
know that I'm prepared to say that it's
totally about sort of the family unit I
think family the one thing that I'm
happy to see now his family is being
more broadly defined mm-hmm we and our
community oftentimes talk about it takes
a village and the family could be the
little old lady cross the street if you
don't know your grandmother she might
essentially become your grandma mm-hmm
in loco parentis the concept in Latin
that that there are a whole bunch of
folks who act as parents to make it all
happen so I think we have to be a little
too careful and I hear the strict
conservatives well it's all of this is
because the family model has degraded us
a little historically I'm not so sure we
as a people in particular ever had that
yeah that's not real yeah I was
mentioning to you before also that I
just went to George Washington's estate
and yes you can go to the slave quarters
and they do a daily memorial now that
and they talk about the men living here
at the time men living here they
sometimes only got it interacts for four
minutes in a day and all sorts of stuff
yeah so you know sometimes when we have
to help people revisit history you know
they're like oh it was great back in the
day yeah not exactly speaking speaking
of history I wasn't planning on going
here but as long as we're talking about
this what do you make of all the
monuments stuff happening right now
because I just read one this week that
at Christchurch and I think it's an
Alexandria they are taking
George the mind you know there I think
it's just a plaque actually right and I
guess there was also a plaque to Robert
II leave that upset some people so they
said alright we're gonna take down
George Washington's as well George
Washington there's no doubt he did own
slaves he freed as many as he legally
could when he died not all of them more
because some of them were technically I
think owned by Martha or her family or
something like that
but as I said they do a great memorial
to them these people were all complex
people who were writing laws to free
people while they owned people I mean
it's a whole freakin thing but me
personally you want my answer for please
I'm glad to but Tim what do you think I
don't think you can take these things
down I think you can put a counter
monument next to them or a plaque that
explains more maybe you could convince
me that they can all be moved to a
museum where then you were gonna learn
about the history but I'm very leery
that there's just no ending here that
we're gonna take down the robert e lee's
stuff we're gonna take down you know
other Confederate stuff but it will
creep to George Washington it will creep
to Thomas Jefferson I was just at the
memorial the words that that man wrote
about what freedom is that's the stuff
we should all care about and I just
feared that there's no ending here I
don't know if that's enough of a
justification not to take anything down
but that's really where my position is
coming from that there it won't end well
not surprisingly I violently agree with
you I I would have accepted either no I
would have given it but frankly you know
there are a couple of aha moments for me
first of all we don't like to
acknowledge this but black people home
slaves in America - that's real I mean
if the litmus test is if you own slaves
somehow we should erase from history or
put you into a museum in a little box so
that only people who visit museums will
learn about right that's why I don't
really like that after I throw it up
there because I know QA that I did at
Claremont McKenna
they are kid asked me and I said that he
said well what if we put him in mines I
said alright we can play with that one a
little bit but to your point if you take
this to its I think illogical end
mmm-hmm we didn't go through and parse
every person's history and we find the
one thing they did that we didn't like
which by the way at that time
at that point in the world may have been
totally the norm yeah I'm not arguing it
was good or bad I'm just saying it was
the way people lived and it was that
what was the more a the folk way
whatever of the time I
I struggle with this I think you put
everything into context when I ride
through and I see a Confederate statue I
was laughing I was in Apple Town
Alexandria the other day yeah I have
past this particular this reach what is
it I was just this robert e lee is the
one that's sitting right in it's just
past i don't know the street of past
King Street I think it is there's a
statue of this guy on horse I've passed
it a number of times and thought well
that's interesting
I've also I live in Washington DC on
Capitol Hill and there are all sorts of
these statues that frankly Charles
Barkley who I don't quote very him I do
a Berkeley impression I was a bargaining
put it down I think which was really
provocative he said frankly most
african-american people aren't thinking
about that damn monument I mean it's
just we have real issues facing our
community and the idea that we have now
gotten preoccupied with these monuments
is bizarre to me and frankly and more
disturbing to me is that it's divisive
yeah anytime you start peeling apart
people's history all of this is sort of
the history of the country the good and
the bad and I think that's the beauty of
telling the story and when I talk to
students about it because I've had this
conversation with some of our students
and I said do you think you know all of
us we go back into our history you're
gonna find out that your grandparents
weren't perfect people you know the
grandfather who beat on your grandmother
who cheated on your grandmother the
grandmother who well let's say back in
the day decided not to have a kid just
had a kid out of wedlock and decide to
give him to an aunt and never
acknowledged and then it was there's so
many
we've all got great bodies got yeah
right and the notion that somehow you've
literally made this person's life less
important because of a decision that
happened I mean all of us are growing on
this journey called life and I just
think we've gotten too serious about it
and it's also frankly divided the
country a country that is way too
divided right now I mean I've never seen
eye
Martin Luther King Lincoln Thurgood
Marshall they have to be like sitting
back somewhere looking at this hand oh
my god I can't believe once we pulled
the rules down change the laws became a
more open and free society none of us
could have thunk that this is where we'd
end up
yeah and you know the easy answer is to
blame it on Trump but the fact of the
matter is this started way before this
has nothing I know so now everyone
everything right now but I'm pretty sure
some even though even the NFL protests
were going on under Obama horse when you
talk about the historical stuff Obama
his first president first four years was
against gay marriage right so we should
be live now twenty years ago it I've got
to take Obama statue or take his library
down or oh don't even start me on that
I'm so sorry on that many countless
examples you know I I was talking to
folks that there was a big discussion
about public schools and you know we
need to send all of our kids to public
schools in sighs timeout timeout timeout
the Obama girls we're gonna go to school
Sidwell I know it's not very very good
for them yeah but then you can't turn
around and say Oh public schools are
wonderful they're great for everyone
when but no the reality is they're good
enough for your children mm-hmm those
are some of the moments when we have to
stop and just pause and say you know
this is it's gotten crazy
that's the point I mean I'm so straight
it with it right now because we're
picking apart people's lives and the
reality is none of us would want someone
to do the same thing on an individual
level with me you want to pick my life
apart you can come out and say I'm a
horrible person
yeah ignore the fact that I have a
beautiful seven-year-old daughter that
my parents are wonderful that I'm a good
son a good but she want to focus on the
one or two decisions that perhaps I
would have been frankly I would have
done them differently if I were 48
yeah I'm not I was 18 Yeah right yeah
yeah it's it's we're just in an
interesting spot I know that's what
you're talking about but it disturbs me
it disturbs me and some very significant
ways that I'm raising a child in this
world in this country in particular
that's not the country I envisioned it
would be yeah do you think there's any
chance that it actually is the country
but it's just the level of noise has
gotten so out of control so when we
think about you know I
talk a lot about social media and how
Twitter is affecting everybody and the
way we all cater news to ourselves and
all that stuff but then I took all of
August offline I shut down I was working
on my book I disappeared for a while and
when I spent more time just I mean I
talked to people for a living but
outside of this room just talking to
random people I think most people do by
everything that you just said there and
I don't think that people are
necessarily as hysterical as maybe we
feel they are do you think that's
possible
or is that I'm just trying to give a
real silver lining for this and I think
you're trying to feel better because as
much as we can we can't just put the
media over in a little box particularly
it used to be a traditional media but
now it's social media and so when you
add all of that it really does influence
the narrative it influences what people
think it means to live in America and
and I do think we're in a very different
place now and you're right every person
in the world doesn't know what's going
on a metaphor it gets charged today the
Verity of Americans don't know or care
it's people who watch the news and who
read and who think about this who and
you know where it matters the vast
majority of Americans are like I'm
trying to keep the lights on I want to
put my kid in school and I want a decent
life and retire with some decent savings
in the bank that's more practical so I
think you're right but the influencers
people like me and you maybe not like
the two of us is the the more liberal
media has just put it out there so far
progressively yeah they're really
crafting the narrative and the message
and it's it's it's something that we
have to pause yeah do you find yourself
with the political home because
obviously I'm in a lockstep with so much
of the things that you're so many of the
things that you're talking about when I
heard you give that speech I was like
yeah yeah yeah well I've been 20 times I
was like yeah yeah yeah okay yeah yeah
do you I mean do you consider yourself
are you in a party or totally
independent so or as when I was in North
Carolina it was called unaffiliated that
was the phrase you weren't an
independent because there were
independents that was the NA third party
so it's unaffiliated us as kept was a
big part of Hillary Clinton's 2008
campaign raised ton of money had her in
my home fundraisers had Erskine Bowles
and his
I mean I was like really really into
that world I did not see that in the
research yeah yes so literally host her
in my home in North Carolina and did a
lot and then fast forward I've become
this last election frankly less enamored
so I was not involved in that campaign I
also wasn't involved in Donald Trump's
campaign I just have decided that I'm
gonna have to figure out where I fit and
right now it's just I'd like to say I'm
an American I'm a patriot I'm trying to
figure out on balance which individual
is looking out for the best interest of
America and that's a very it's a lonely
place sometimes because you know
weirdness by cops right you know year
there were Democrat or Republican and
some call themselves independents but
the reality is they lean left or right
I'm sort of in the middle there are
things that I think I would take
positions that I take that are more
conservatively aligned and then there
are times when it's more than less
conservatively or more liberally aligned
but I don't think you can just fall into
a box I really don't I think that's the
problem frankly there are some issues
that I really take a strong position on
I mean we were just oh this is so just
the other thing we'll talk about
something I was at the advancing justice
seminar it's advance of Justice summit
which is hosted by the Charles Koch
foundation a big discussion around
reducing the number of incarcerated
Americans and so someone threw out by
2020 we want to reduce the number of
people incarcerated by 50% and I pause
and I said well that's dumb
suppose 30% of those people really
should be incarcerated yeah suppose
they're not they should they absolutely
cannot be put back on the streets you're
telling me you're thinking through is
just someone yells at a brain thinking
and I'm thinking it through Bertie lordy
do these we're going to tell you why cuz
it bothered me cuz here's the deal I
grew up in one of those fragile
communities I grew up and I shared this
with the group I said I grew up in the
area and my grandmother I'll never
forget this I'll never forget riding up
to high school people would romp to our
windows she you know 60-plus your old
grandmother and me in an ROTC uniform
going to high school
drug dealers run up to our windows
prostitutes are standing on the corner
in mourning this is 7:30 8 o'clock in
the morning next to a school
man ok but this was the community my
grandmother one day I'll never forget it
she said they wouldn't allow this in
white town they would never put up with
this in white down
she was so bothered so she became
committed she called a demanded police
she demanded that you removed these
people from our community and so fast
forward you just want to release release
them all back to our community and I
said this to one of the attendees I said
here's a problem that sounds great and
it's great for you because they're not
coming back to your community that's
that's why this isn't your problem if
you release 50 percent of these people
where do you think they're coming and
not come into suburbia they're going to
show back up in the communities and
continue terrorizing and negatively
impact in the community so on that plan
I tell that story to say you know listen
I am passionate about it I am Bobby
I appreciate well-intended people yeah
thinking that just releasing half the
people who are currently incarcerated
into our communities is a good thing but
they don't think about the impact of
that when my kid can't go out and play
in the streets for being shot my kid
can't my daughter has to walk past these
scantily clad women who were selling
themselves and she begins to think
that's normal that's not the world and
you may call that a non-violent offender
but it's not nonviolent it's actually
more violent because it's working into
the psyche young people there's so much
there because you could also look at
that and go well a certain amount of
those people are in there for drug
offenses not selling right and and if
they had had better representation or
more money they would have never been in
jail in the first place and their
parents or so you can't just blame the
government's and that's the thing that's
what we're going to get to 20 and blame
the system for not giving them good
lawyers and the system for incarcerate
them too long and all of that and you
forget that a lot of that stuff started
a lot earlier in their lives now you
know you took it back to the this guy
the conservative point that's right it's
not that scared because by the what my
only point is it doesn't have to be my
dad yeah it has to be someone it could
be a school teacher that helped infuse
morals and the sense of right and wrong
into that kid but we've got to go back
we can't just wake up and say okay now
you've got a 19 year old who has a long
criminal history no regard for anyone or
anything
and say we just think he or she should
not be incarcerated okay then pray tell
what are you going to do about the head
yeah you ever get an answer to that I
mean if you let these people out I get
that I'm probably with you okay
came from a bad place didn't have the
proper support potentially in jail for
doing drugs not even selling them so the
idea is okay you want to get this person
out of jail even if even if it's just an
economic thing you don't want to have
the system spending money that's right
but now you put them out there you still
have some responsibility I think right
that the system or whatever you want to
call it has some responsibility to make
sure that now you just don't toss this
back into the mix of and what got them
there in the first place all right and
how do you fix that
that is the big question I mean the easy
answer is release them and then what I
would say and then what and the thing
that bothers me is that many of the
people who advocate for this release
release release don't have to answer the
question what because they have they
live in neighborhoods with gate gated
neighborhoods with a lot of police
protection etc so they're not impacted
by they just want to once you get them
out and we we see this listen and
unfortunately with individuals who
suffer with mental mental illness so you
you want them out and then what what are
you gonna do now and that's someone
else's problem and the system as you
call it the non system hasn't answered
that question
[Music]
alright let's shift a little bit to some
specific issues because I think we've
done a nice little broad okay job to
start here you mentioned to me briefly
something about daca that I thought was
really interesting how the black
community is sort of split on this can
yeah yeah you know daca is on its
surface it's an easy it should be easy
but what I've come talking about the
complexity of and the nuances so
increasingly our students on HBCU
campuses are raising they have real beef
with this is the way they describe it so
one of the students put it and it made
me pause cuz I was like that's an easy
one you're not gonna send to a million
people home these kids were brought here
by their parents didn't have a choice if
I tell my daughter were going somewhere
she's going right so that's what it's oh
I get it yeah and then one of the young
women put it best she said you know
think about the she called it she said
the irony of this is that they're very
the America is are rallying around
providing not only the ability for these
students to enroll in school but
oftentimes full scholarships for these
students the daca students while she
said and Here I am the legal descendant
of slaves we were forced to come here
and I have to figure out how to pay for
my education and so there's this tension
there's real tension and they have to
whisper it so I asked her I said well
why don't you just talk about that in
class and she said oh I would be killed
that you can't talk about that in class
she said but there's an underground sort
of conversation about that doesn't seem
but there if America has enough money to
provide additional scholarship
assistance to students then shouldn't
you take care of people like us who were
brought here our parents were brought
here and we truly are and so I was like
wow that's really it was a really hadn't
thought about it yeah made me pause
there's also a recent article I think
it's the Chicago times where a guy wrote
an editorial about Rahm Emanuel wants to
spend one or two million dollars on
providing IDs for undocumented
immigrants and the black aldermen had a
meltdown I mean literally is quoted all
over the papers saying this is absurd
and
nufs enough we have Americans here
african-americans in Chicago who need XY
and Z and instead you want to go spend a
bit so there's a tension America is that
a really inflection point that's just
not black and white or conservative and
liberal there's tension now amongst
people of color yeah and it seems to me
that obviously that conversation is good
and it's nice to hear that a student
said something to you that made you
reevaluate because that shows you
practice what you preach obviously
that's right is there some is there
who's the leader right now if there I
know I know you probably get this one
all the time and I don't even like the
question in a certain way no but I could
but but who should black America
whatever that is it's so it's so stupid
talking about that stuff like who should
be in your opinion should the black
community be turning to to make some
sense of this because there's the usual
cast of characters we can name all the
ones that you don't like that are on MSN
I see it today and I don't like them
either so let's just forget those guys
but others some people that we should be
looking at that and I don't even mean
just black America but no for people
that really care that's very that's
right about freedom so you make the good
point I don't even know America
generally you know that we can identify
someone who is sane and rational and
logical and thoughtful but in the
african-american community you've nailed
it
I we had a generation of leaders and
they were right for that era and what
was going on fast forward 20 30 years
I'm not sure and I've actually sat with
a group of my counterparts you know 40s
successful and said who's the leader
who's the voice what voice captures
what's happening in afternoon American
community not to be fair it's not
monolithic African of course you know
like any other but that's why I don't
write that's why we don't like it yeah
but it was never monolithic but we had
leaders aren't even the king was a
leader although you know he he wasn't
from industry he didn't you know so but
still he represented just he caught and
captured the voice of the community I
have to honestly say and it's something
that bothers me I don't know who that
person is and and I'm not so sure that
if you asked him black people none of
them would say I'm not sure who that
leader is yeah and it's so complex
because you remember a couple years ago
when Oprah said the thing about how what
we just need these all
racists to die and issues Reverend she
was referencing some people's
grandmothers and grandfathers and I
remember thinking and I have no beef
with old guys but I remember hearing
that and thinking this is so dangerous
it gets back to what we were talking
about earlier about how you just live in
your times and like no one wants to look
at their grandparents who live grew up
in a different time thing I don't wait
till you just drop dead so you can't
vote anymore with the and it makes me
think huh you know I had as my
grandmother taught school 46 years in
Brown County Florida and I remembered
she said something to me now and I think
the world of my grandmother's she's
still like 93 years old 94 just had a
birthday and I remembered going down to
the University of Miami and I came home
and I was said I think I've met someone
and it was she assumed it was a white
woman because I'm in a majority
institution you know lily-white
University of Miami and she said son I'd
rather you bring a man home
Allan now this is someone who I adore
and I think the world of her but I had
to stop and pause it stuck me I remember
that I'd rather you bring a man home
than a white woman and I had to realize
that a lot of folks hold these racial so
that things and they are products of
their era like right so when I see you
know an older 90 year old 80 year old
white guy who has and harbors some
racial animus I wasn't around then I
can't really put that in context I'm not
justifying it I'm not saying it's right
or wrong but what I am saying to your
earlier point is I love my grandmother
and if you tried to attack my
grandmother because she espoused that
worldview I would attack you yeah
because I look at the totality of her
contributions to this country and her
her racist tendencies are one a product
of the error that she grew up in but
they are also a very very small part of
the full woman that I know yes and
that's the key part everyone wants to
define everybody said earlier you could
figure out something that you did when
you were 18 but something that I did
when I was 26 and gold man a four
decision
right exactly but that's that's the
point that we're just pieces that's
right of all of this easy too and that's
that's a problem we just want to
collapse on the one thing that someone
did that's by the way unpopular now what
do you think Martin Luther King would
would think about the identity politics
stuff it's I I would like to think and
by the way I say that because you read
so many versions of what Martin fought
I've heard people say he was a
Republican then I've heard people help
he's a womanizer he said this you just
don't know yeah I think you can make
interesting argument suppose that he was
a conservative and now he doesn't want
his children to be judged by the color
of their skin that actually sounds a
little more like a conservative idea
because that's not an identity politics
idea yet hit a lot of his economic stuff
was bearing more towards socialism in a
way so I think you can argue both but I
think on balance I think he would I
believe that he would be looking he's
looking down saying you know no system
is perfect no set of rules is perfect
but this is a lot better people today
than it was what we inherited back then
mmm-hmm is far worse than what you have
today so why don't we look at the
progress that was made and figure out
how we build on it I'd like to think
that because his nature was one of
working together finding commonality and
peaceful protests you know people now
you know not allowing people to talk
when you disagree with them literally
shouting them down think about that era
when Martin Luther King we were the
minority then we're clearly I mean
really a minority literally they they
could have silenced him by yelling and
shouting him down and somehow the
country allowed that voice to - and
people embraced it because they listened
to it even people who were probably not
inclined to agree with him
you know forth at that time yeah but by
listening they said huh maybe he's done
to something and it really piqued their
heart it got to the heart and said you
know what I'm this is probably not the
right way to think about my fellow
Americans it was because they listened
but if you aren't even being if you
can't hear if you're unwilling to listen
Martin has to be sad right now yeah
yeah that I was just at the mind minute
I was telling you how I was just in DC
gone all these things and that's what I
felt I just felt things have gotten so
much better for everybody it doesn't
mean right there isn't racism it doesn't
mean some people don't like gay people
or any of those things but we are laws
basically are fair and it's like where
else are they doing it better that's
right well why are you gonna move
somewhere and I said the same thing
right after even after the Trump
election you know I remember all of
those folks if he's elected I'm leaving
the country no she's still here right
all of these folks are Rosie's name the
group who all thought they're gonna
leave the country I'm like you're not
going anywhere I don't want to go too
far down the Trump thing unless you want
to go there but no but do you think that
whatever is happening with him right now
and as you said as we're taping this
today mana for it was was indicted by
the FBI it sounds like it's not even
directly about the Trump all right aim
that it's about some Ukraine stuff
before book but we'll see where all that
plays out but as a general rule what do
you make of what's happened because to
me what I keep trying to say is if you
just let go of the tweets for a minute
you're like over the media hysteria
basically nothing bad has happened
basically well to two things first of
all you'll Yvonne I know it's hard to
get rid of it no no you've only had
eight months up so yeah nothing bad
could really happen in eight months
anyway
this is a republic that has been around
for a very long time it's gonna be
around a long time after him so that's
the beginning the other thing is it goes
back to this media thing if you are can
you continue above information that says
everything this person does is bad at
some point you believe it mm-hmm right
and I think that's a part of it he's
trying to figure it out
could he stay off the tweet a little bit
Twitter off yes yeah could he be a
little bit more presidential he'll he
admitted it this weekend when he said
that but I'm about to say about Michael
Moore great well
news alert President Trump several of
those sorts some things have not been
president so I'm glad you're
acknowledging yeah but nobody can't
though great cuz that's what got him
there that's what's got him there and
that that's what people forget it worked
and frankly as much as we talked about
he's not reflecting America yes he does
he you know
three million Americans voted for him 46
for Hillary and people don't factor the
sin but three million Hillary won the
state of great state of California or
the by 3 million votes
people forget that so pull those that 3
million person spread was like here yeah
well for the record I in California
voted for Gary Johnson judge me however
you and all to another judge me however
you want but I suspect you would ally
fell out of the ideas of Gary I did in
fact I did yeah but you know we knew he
wasn't gonna win now that's a whole
different conversation but I but I I'm
in California it didn't matter which
right that's like me in Washington DC
yeah I don't for the Democratic
candidate is gonna win full-stop right
yeah and again that gets back to the
issue this country is just you're you're
in one camp or the other and it is when
you think 46 and 43 million people we're
calling we're really divided I mean I
just don't even know where the center is
anymore
mmm-hmm that's that's troubling so to me
the center basically is somewhat
economically conservative in that yes
you earn your money you should keep it
and I thought so the re always argue
that's the best way if you hate Trump
the best way to limit government is to
stop giving it so much money and power
right because sometimes you know what
you might get Bernie and he can use a
lot of power that you like but then
sometimes you're gonna get a guy you
don't like so let's just stop giving
them so much power but in a weird way
does this all show that our system is
working properly
well that's you know you mentioned
earlier this is it's not a perfect
system but I don't there's no other
place in the world I'd rather be I thank
God every day when I wake up and and so
you know that I'm here and cuz we could
have all been born somewhere else and
this could have been a really bad
situation it's not a perfect union but
we're working towards it and that's the
optimism but it's only if we have
conversations like this the two of us
this doesn't appear on mainstream
television by the way that's the thing
that I gotta figure out how to get you
hey let me be your age right but we have
to get I believe you could do is I don't
even know that I want it but I believe
they can do it really could because this
voice is what's missing
you're either MSNBC or Fox News you're
Rachel or you're Hannity
and that by the way doesn't get us any
closer to fixing this because people
then divide out yeah that's what we've
got to do because rational people can I
think reasonable people can come to some
conclusions that this is good for all of
us yeah you know relating this to sort
of where we started as you're saying
this I'm thinking you know there's
something interesting here if this
identity politics stuff wins the day and
they start taking down more monuments
and we start judging Thomas Jefferson
and the rest of the founders on the
morals of today it's not just that we'll
remove them but we'll actually all of
their good ideas all of their good ideas
will have to go away
they won't even if you like a lot of
those good ideas you mean like they
won't just magically keep some of the
ideas what you're gonna actually remove
all of those ideas and then what are we
left to it and it ain't pretty right and
and it's not America that that's the
reality it's not America and that's
something that we've all got to come to
grips with is that this is not a good
direction the trajectory is all wrong
I'm pleased to say and all of us in the
markets are performing the financially
you'll do well but by the way if you
don't have any money you're not
participating in the markets anyway
right right so people like the two of us
we're gonna do fine yeah and our
families and significant others and
stakeholders are gonna do fine it's the
rest of these folks who are being left
out and they unfortunately are buying
into this narrative that America is bad
and somehow the magic fix is to tax the
wealthy like oh where does that end like
and so is there is the appeal of that
just because it's sort of lazy thinking
you know you mean like it just doesn't
take much to be like I want what
somebody else has like it's kind of an
easy answer like I don't have somebody
all got they should give me some of that
like you don't have to think that hard
relax it to think harder to understand
why you shouldn't or don't deserve
someone else's money let's see I don't I
and why maybe but it's also equally lazy
to think if I were you know a
millionaire I wouldn't want to give more
of my money than someone else if I
earned it yeah even if I bought a
freaking lottery ticket you know just
basic take some person who's from a
community and who's got limited
resources and you say to them you won
the lottery tomorrow you won two million
dollars five million of it goes to the
federal government in your state how
does that make you bad yes
that's lazy I mean you don't even think
a lot to say that's not a good result
right yeah so I don't know why this is I
don't know that it's easy I think it's
we have just pounded into people's heads
that taking that the rich people are bad
you're vilified for going to work every
day and making some good decisions and
some luck and some God and some fate all
of that in the totality you're bad for
having done well and the media plays it
consistent they love it you believe it
yeah you believe it what do you think is
the right amount of government for us to
have as much as we need I know that's
not a great answer but I would literally
I'm sort of concerned not sort of I'm
very conservative in that respect I
don't think you can have no government
cuz then you have anarchy
we need so you know what Mad Max right I
don't want that I mean if my house burns
down I want a police department to show
up I don't have to rely on my three
neighbors with buckets to come so I've
got a fire department to show up so I
think government the infrastructure is
important of any society that will
endure I do think that we've gotten too
far though when you have just huge
bureaucracy and departments designed to
solve problems that frankly will solve
themselves amongst people yeah but we
become completely dependent on it is
there any way to scale it back that's
one of the questions I try to ask a lot
of my more libertarian guests yes like
it seems like this this thing has gotten
so big and when you factor it in with
you know handouts and all of this stuff
that if you were ever to take it back a
lot of people think will you just be
screwing over all the poor people all
that then I have some people who come on
and say no you just cut it tomorrow and
we see what happens will charities come
in will churches and synagogues and
mosques and all that will they pick up
the slack you know will if you cut the
funding to Planned Parenthood would
Barbara Streisand and Rosie and the rest
of them suddenly put some of their money
towards that I tend to think the answer
is yes me too I do but how do you how do
you get that point across to people well
they're not going to do it unless force
to do it so I think so that's something
to be said for just
stop I mean what we saw Puerto Rico is a
classic example we're all forced you
know worried about what's happening in
Puerto Rico but this didn't start with a
hurricane mm-hmm Puerto Rico is a
disaster I mean when I read something I
was down there last year and they said
70 or so percent of the population work
for the government like that is gotten
out of control and the only way you fix
that you can't come in and say hey guys
50 percent of you all should give up
your government jobs right for us to get
this right no you just have to kind of
just happen you just have to and that's
the frankly that's the opportunity and I
want to be careful here because I don't
want I didn't I'm not a Trump surrogate
or anything else but that's the
opportunity for someone like him I think
we have just elected our first
independent president I think it's the
first time that America has had someone
who says what they think forgot of her
bad butt and who is prepared to be
unpopular because to make these sorts of
decisions you've got to be unpopular and
okay with that
so was that his best line during the
campaign when he said basically to the
black community he was like what do you
got to lose you think it was an actual
it ended up being a good line because it
sound him off when I heard it and then
I've talked to a lot of people and they
kind of were like yeah all these
Democratic run cities Chicago Atlanta
Ferguson that's where the worst so it's
funny I remembered I knew I know where I
was at that moment when that happened
and I was with a group of my friends and
one of my friends who is as liberal as
they come I've never said me he trips up
and he's dead to me it was this moment
like when you eat something that's
bitter at first and then you're like
what that tastes good ultimately yeah
and he said he's on to something and
that was when I knew that actually
resonated I didn't feel good at first I
mean I got it check because it was a
little dismissive and frankly the
african-american community is still
enjoying the fact that we elected our
first african-american president and
frankly so are a lot of non African
Americans right it was a big deal so
they felt like it was a shot at Obama
that's that was the issue mm-hmm if you
had taken Obama out of the equation
having been the president it was a
totally reasonable state
to say whoever the guy was before he
didn't meaningfully change your life I
am prepared to do what he have to lose
so I think you just if you took a bomb
out of it and the Pratt associated with
him being you know a first I think it
was totally logical yeah ironically I
think you can make a great argument that
the President himself whether it's Obama
or Trump or anybody else shouldn't have
that much power over your life well that
would be my greater solution here that's
my attitude people say well you know I
wouldn't want to have lunch with Donald
Trump I said and you're not that's easy
I wonder if my president to do two
things literally I have sort of drawn it
down to this national security and
Economic Security
I want the economy conning me to be
strong globally I want that money and
then I want to make sure that the
homeland is secure in the context of a
global contest so it's not just domestic
but you got to do some things uh
nationally to protect your homeland
those two things I don't care what the
president thinks about much of anything
because he's a man just like I am then
you are so he'll have an opinion about X
and that's good for him there's Supreme
Court as Congress has all of that stuff
but I just want them to do two things
economic security and what I'll call
homeland but security national security
is it funny to you how everybody's sort
of flipped their opinions on almost
everything these days cuz as you're
saying that I'm thinking if we just go
back 20 minutes when we were talking
about daca it's like well suddenly
Democrats because they didn't like what
Trump is doing we're fighting for states
rights and it's like yeah I want you
guys to fight for states rights all the
time could then I'll start voting with
you again well look at the Obamacare the
new proposed Affordable Health Care Act
rather you know the idea is block grant
it to the states I thought that's what
we all want right it's and I was
surprised to see some states actually no
we don't want it what do you mean you
don't want it the ability of mr. MS
governor to manage and take care of your
citizenry with your dollars without the
intervention of some people in
Washington DC who know nothing about
what happens in Spokane Washington you
don't want and to me that's like the
most like perfect example of how screwed
up our system is that a governor who's
the executor of the state would be like
none
the thing that I'm supposed to do you do
let's send it over there that way I'm
free in the clear that's like the worst
that's why people hate politicians it's
why people hate the media it's like
holding I want I live in California
which probably they're probably gonna
execute it for a little free tonight a
little bit a little libertarian you know
and it believe me if they if they secede
from the union I'm really can I move in
with put that the Iowa that's what I do
but but that point basically of
everything's being flipped right now
like everyone's kind of all over the
place it's actually cool I mean that's I
know so many people are depressed about
it but what I've been trying to say is
there's opportunity here it doesn't mean
it's gonna be bad it doesn't mean it's
gonna be good but let's get in there and
fight for what you believe even if you
believe in the stuff that I abhor right
right but but they're lazy I mean that
you use the right where people are lazy
this is actually fascinating to watch
now I want to separate earlier I said
and you know I'm nervous about where
this is going
that's true I'm hopeful I'm not
necessarily optimistic and there's a
difference right yeah but I do enjoy
watching the process the sausage-making
I do like to see that ultimately you
know if you go back and look at some of
the at least the reports of the early
founding fathers it was ugly they hated
each other it was divided like nothing
you've ever seen and all of the what we
you know referred to as going on in
Congress right now hell it happened back
then too this might be the American
experience right and and you we just in
time what we do is we put a painting we
tell a story around it and it looks so
wonderful and dramatic but the reality
is it's ugly you know
operating in this sort of a government
this this model of governing is is ugly
yeah and it's got to be ugly right I
mean what's the option I mean I think
that's what people don't understand it's
like if anything's gonna work it kinda
has to be ugly that I mean the sausage
factories all right think nobody wants
to see how it gets made but I don't like
it no she liked it while I was reading
we have to dad know you've seen it the
continent son Boehner is now talking
about what happened you know God
man's Christmas brings in I you know and
the big idea that you know some
literally said got either pulled a gun
or a knife on him or something one of
his fellow members in Congress and it's
just fascinated literally he said and
but that's and that's within the party
yeah
so the idea that somehow the tension is
is bad maybe not so much yeah it's also
funny cuz like you know you'll always
hear all the all these media people and
politicians be like house of cards is
the most realistic show ever it's like
well there's an awful lot of murder and
drug use and evil backdoor deals and
you're just you guys are all kind of
telling us that's right they're all
showing it to us all right well we could
go a rabbit hole on that one so let's
let's shift to your future because you
mentioned you mentioned earlier so you
are leaving the organization that
basically the end of next month right
and where are you going what are you
doing going to run an organization
called the Society for Human Resource
Management sure and it's the world's
largest association dedicated to human
resources and so trade association for
the profession of human resources
professionals and you know so if some
have said wow that's kind of out there
well no it isn't for for a couple of
reasons first of all I've been in higher
ed for the last 75 years if you ask 9
out of 10 college students why did you
go to college is to get a good job
period that's so it's a very natural
kind of thing there's no point of going
if this doesn't turn into some way to
provide the other thing though is it's a
natural sort of evolution in my career I
now understand higher ed actually I
think I have a really good understanding
of all of the education so P K through
16 mmm-hmm we've now got it connected
there's not an article that comes out
where employers say the system is not
giving me what I want the students who
graduating don't have the skills that we
need and so they're frustrated because
I'm paying taxes to pay for this system
educational system and the what comes
out on the other hand the assembly line
model is Right really bad I pay for all
of this and at the end the car I don't
like it yeah so I think this gives me an
opportunity to take what I've done for
the last seven and a half years and now
take get industry bring the two together
and say let's figure out how to make
this system work we're spending a lot of
money as a country
education and to what end so what are
some of the ways you could shift
education I mean I think the basic
premises of get people to listen and get
people to really understand what they
believe in but is there something that's
like a little more concrete that you're
gonna go in and be like guys let's this
is what we got to change yeah you know
you know the current administration is
talking a lot about apprenticeships for
example the endgame can't be everyone
goes to four-year college and I think we
went that way for too long you know that
didn't work so the idea is to figure out
credentialing to figure out what are the
specific skills that one needs to go
into the 21st century economy industry
has to tell us that since they are
ultimately the consumer of this
education product yeah and then we got
to go back and say okay now you've got a
tweak your system I know you all don't
like being vocations vocational schools
and you want to teach people how to
think and solve the world's problems but
the vast majority of the folks who come
through your system are doing what
they're trying to get a jobs yeah so
that's what we're gonna do it concretely
bringing those education and industry
together and say let's figure this out
we've got to rethink and talk about
disruption I predict that higher
education in particular is going to be
disrupted in a way as a business as a
sector like nothing you've ever seen the
pieces are all there for that right now
because we see the schools that a lot of
the schools that have gone down the SJW
route are really struggling Mizzou is
majorly struggling enrollment we know
Evergreen State struggling I mean well
you have another problem America
Americans just had fewer babies the
reality is we we've seen there fewer
students graduating high school this
year than last year and the year before
so what we're seeing is a problem you're
just not going to have the same number
of bodies to come into that traditional
college environment that we created with
dorms and everything else so now we've
our non-traditional student has to be
our traditional student yeah that's got
to be a little ironic for you in a way
you come from the higher ed thing you
care so much about it and yet you can
also acknowledge that a certain amount
of people just because of the reality of
economics don't necessarily need all of
that education that's you know that's
right and it's going to be lifelong you
know it's the idea we came out of the
generation where you get your education
your masters your masters your doctor
whatever you get and then you go into
the workplace
do it for 30 years and you retire now
and now because the economy is changing
so much every five to seven years
industries go away that we were taught
to participate in they go away and so
that's I'm so excited about that finally
you know sort of related to that America
is browning and graying at once so
underlying all of this is we've got to
figure out how to get the system to
appreciate a very different America it's
not black and white anymore it's brown
it's yellow it's everything and how
these workers as they come out of
college or whatever their educational
backgrounds are when they come into the
workplace how do we grow our economy and
we've got to use people to do it right
and that's what I'm excited about sure
and higher education and just trying to
figure out how to tie that all together
yeah well I gotta tell you man I
thoroughly enjoyed this I'm not
surprised because as I said I saw it
once and I was like this guy is gonna do
it but I think the real beauty of this
is that you're not just saying this
stuff you're actually out there doing it
and I believe it that's right I don't
believe you know this isn't about my
desire to run for office or to get a job
I really believe this this is something
that it keeps me up at night how can
people like the two of us change the
narrative thank you thank you well I
feel like I got I gotta give you one
more here that'll all right what would
you say what would you say that well
thank you but what would you say then to
the to the people whether they're
college students right now or whether
they're you know middle-aged whatever it
is that want to get in the fight but are
afraid because of all the silencing
factors you know what I mean ya know two
things first of all you need courage you
you've got a intestinal courage you got
just go down and decide this is the pit
this is where I want to go and by the
way that means transferring schools if
that means changing the people you spend
time around because you know that can be
debilitating in some ways then do it I
mean it's just the only way to do it the
other thing is I would encourage all
Americans we've got to listen more the
most frustrating thing to me now is
we're so busy talking and frankly
talking over others that we just won't
pause and listen that's the beginning of
changing the narrative because as you're
listening you're going to one the other
person will
back to you now because you've listened
to them and in the process you actually
might learn something you might say you
know the world is a little different
than I perceived it to be because I got
it from someone else's perspective
that's the beauty of diversity by the
way mm-hmm it's not just gender and
raised in national origin its diverse
perspectives how another person sees the
world if we can get those two things
down first of all listen
but then courage it takes a lot frankly
for me to be right here the best thing
in the world if I aspire to be a
congressman and a member of you know the
CBC and dah dah dah there's a narrative
that I'm supposed to follow and you've
got to decide that that that doesn't
matter what's more important is that the
American story a hundred years from now
is is a much better story because I was
here I loved it that's a closing
statement and for more on Johnny you
guys can follow him on the Twitter
machine it's at Johnny C Taylor jr.
[Music]
you